the sitting resume honorable members
last night the Parliament of the United
Kingdom voted by Massa majority against
the agreements negotiated with the
European Union over the last few years
we take a note of that vote albeit with
a degree of regret but we respect the
view of the majority represented in the
House of Commons we need to interpret
this vote in the right way it's not so
much these it's not that the forces who
voted against we're on the same
wavelength there were those who want to
close things with the European Union in
the future for example via a customs
union it's too early to analyze the
consequences of the vote but we're
certainly not looking at the New Deal
scenario there was no majority in
Westminster for that idea either
that remains there are two negative
majorities in Westminster one against
the agreement and one against the
prospect of the itíd Kingdom withdrawing
for European Union without your image
but there's no positive majority there
we therefore trust that start cremate to
work which will ensure that as fast as
possible we can find a shared solution
and we to discover how the British
government intends to proceed we have
ambitions for our future relationship
with the United Kingdom not discuss that
the British government would also be
ambitious and revisit the red lines it
set the European Parliament has full
faith in our negotiated Michel Barnier
who in a moderate intelligent and wise
way oversaw the negotiations with the
United Kingdom if it proves impossible
to raise the level of ambition we would
face the prospect of a No Deal
which would lose situation for everyone
we'd need to prepare for the prospect of
the UK leaving without an agreement I
think it's only right and proper and
this is the position of the European
Parliament to focus first of all on the
citizens of the European Union living in
the United Kingdom and British citizens
living in the rest of Europe because
they are suffering from uncertainty and
they would be the first victims of a
disorderly withdrawal of the United
Kingdom we will continue closely to
follow drizzles on the Irish issue also
we must ensure that the border between
Northern Ireland and the Republic of
Ireland is a flexible one while
upholding the health of European farming
and Industry we must of course absurdist
retain the unity amongst the member
states that we manage to build up over
the the course of these long and
difficult negotiations that unity shows
that their difficult times the European
Union is really there and is in a
position to adopt a cohesive political
position
it's a moral debate ito rule well now
open the debate on the council and
Commission statements on the UK's
withdrawal on behalf of the council miss
Melania Church has the floor president
honourable members last November the
European Council endorsed the agreement
on the withdrawal of the UK from the EU
and the euro item the European Council
also approved the political declaration
setting out the framework for the future
relationship between the EU and the UK
and restated the union's determination
to have as close as possible a
partnership with the UK in the future
this outcome would not have been
possible without the sense of unity
shared purpose and responsibility
amongst the EU 27 member states as well
as amongst the EU institutions today
having just learned the outcome of the
meaningful vote in Westminster we cannot
but regret this outcome this makes a
disorderly exit of the UK more likely
such a scenario will have serious
consequences for all over for all of us
but in particular for the UK addressing
these consequences will no doubt call
for the same unity shared purpose and
responsibility among member states and
the EU institutions given the many
conflicting messages that have been
passed in the UK before during the
debates leading to the vote on all sides
of the political spectrum it is hard to
single out one particular explanation of
this outcome
this outcome is of course not the end of
the game while having been cleared at an
ingot renegotiation of the agreement is
not on the cards we should stand ready
to act once the UK government will have
clarified what this result meant means
for the UK ratification process and what
should be the next steps in the meantime
as repeatedly called for by the European
Council in its invitation to the
Commission the European Parliament and
the council to take the necessary steps
we continue the ratification process in
the EU in this respect I am pleased to
mention that last week already the
council adopted its decision on the
signing of the agreement and proved its
decision on its conclusion as well as
the request for the consent of the
Parliament the responsibility for
ensuring the UK ratification of the deal
remains with the UK government our
determination to proceed should however
comfort the UK government in its effort
to complete their part of the
ratification process the final result
both in terms of timing and content is
however far from certain we therefore
have to continue our preparation for all
outcomes including a No Deal scenario we
do not want such a situation but we will
properly prepared for it if it happens
the preparedness and contingency
dimension of brexit should therefore
take a greater importance at you and
national level building on the solid
work already underway this means of
course extra legislative work at this
late stage of the legislature but we are
confident that the
European Parliament will race to the
challenge in the interest of all
stakeholders the presidency with your
cooperation is in any event determined
to facilitate the adoption of the
necessary contingency measures in good
time thank you very much for your
attention
libero Laurel which a presenter a
commissioner appearance Timmerman
enacted the fall to France two months
the vice-president of the Commission
instance the vote last night in the
House of Commons was crystal clear the
withdrawal agreement has been rejected
and now we will have to look for a way
forward the Commission regrets the
rejection of the withdrawal agreement as
representative of the counsellor said
because we do believe this was the best
possible outcome in a situation where
two parties were negotiating looking
after each owns interest the Commission
negotiated Michel Barnier did remarkable
job in negotiating on behalf of the 27
the British government negotiated on
behalf of the United Kingdom and we do
believe the outcome of that negotiation
led to withdrawal agreements which did
as little harm as possible and nobody
should be under any illusion brexit does
harm it does harm to the United Kingdom
it does harm to the European Union and
we are under an obligation as
politicians to limit the harm to the
absolute minimum possible and we do
believe that withdrawal agreements
delivered on that obligation now I think
it's not for us to speculate on what
sort of brexit we will have we will now
have to wait for what's going to happen
in the House of Commons in the United
Kingdom for the position of the British
government and the British Parliament
and we will have to take it from there
but we're also under an obligation to
make sure that we're prepared for any
possible outcome including disorganised
no deal brexit which would have
far-reaching consequences both for the
United King
and for the European Union but the
Commission will be well prepared to make
sure that we react to any possible
outcome and as the representative of
Council said we'll continue our process
of ratification of the withdrawal
agreement since it was agreed with the
United Kingdom government it is and
remains in our view the best possible
outcome front to ensure an orderly
withdrawal and let me end with a quote
by CS Lewis we can't go back and change
the beginning but we can start where we
are and change the ending thank you
[Applause]
or a libero Lyle Kapoor the next speaker
is the hand of the European Union's
because I think Tim Mischel dong-yi
Thank You mr. president for giving me
the floor
ladies and gentlemen member of the
Parliament vice president I'm Secretary
of State the European Power Commission
takes note of the votes of Commons last
night as said by our first vice
president France Timmerman's the outs of
comments voted yesterday with a clear
crystal clear majority against the wish
to our women which european council
agreed with the British government in
November and which you welcomed as the
European Parliament right now it's too
early to assess all the consequences of
this vote
we have always respected and we continue
to respect the democratic parliamentary
debate in the UK and I will not
speculate on the different scenarios
what yesterday's vote showed that the
political conditions for the
ratification of the wisdom agreement are
not yet there in London we regret
perform lay this vote as president
Juncker has said and this regret ladies
and gentlemen is obviously also linked
to the intense work we have done
together with you with your breakfast in
group for two years but also with the
British government based on the red
lines of the British government and
based on the realities of living
do you know all Cato we profoundly
regret this vote because we built this
withdrawal agreement together with the
British government on an objective basis
taking into account our shared demands
to ensure that we don't have a border
with
and preserving allowing the UK to
preserve the integrity of its territory
and together with the British government
we mapped out the framework for the
future relationship which we would like
to be as close and ambitious as possible
and as the British red lines will allow
ladies and gentlemen listening to the
public statements made by the members of
the chamber of Commons of the House of
Commons we regret to say made us sad
they were of course due to various
motivations sometimes quite
contradictory or opposing views
objectively speaking this vote is not a
clear manifestation of a positive
majority which would define an
alternative project an alternative to as
a proposal on the table today so in this
context as mr. Timmerman said it's up to
the British authorities today or
tomorrow to assess the outcome of this
vote and up to the British government to
indicate how we are to take things
forward on the 29th of March towards an
orderly withdrawal as the president of
the European Council mr. tusk reminded
us last night ladies and gentlemen
contrary to what has been said over the
last few days or weeks the agreement
that we reached with the British
government
it's almost 600 pages long is a good
agreement actually it is the result of
course of a compromise but it's the best
possible compromise and again we worked
in an objective manner this brings legal
certainty everywhere where brexit has
actually created uncertainties so as is
the case in all separations certainty
for the citizens for the UK citizens for
the European citizens of the other 27
member states of
the EU their rights are now guaranteed
sustainably these rights have always
been our priority your priority here in
the European Parliament and protecting
these rights will continue to be our
priority whatever the outcome now public
or private bodies whether we're talking
about the UK or authorities in the
various 27 member states all the
undergoing programs will be maintained
thanks to the agreement that we have
reached security and stability for
Ireland and Northern Ireland a return of
a hard border would be avoided thanks to
a solution which would preserve the
integrity of the United Kingdom on the
one hand and the single market on the
other respecting the respect with the
respect of the Good Friday Belfast
agreement which we committed ourselves
to respecting and this is why the
backstop ladies and gentlemen which we
agreed to with the UK must remain a
backstop it must remain a credible
backstop the backstop must be a backstop
it must be credible security for
administration's and businesses who
would be given a transitional period
the only legal basis I might remind you
is the withdrawal agreement under which
they would have time to prepare and
adapt to the new situation so this
compromise also of course gives us with
the transition time to negotiate our
future relationship on the basis of a
political declaration which we have also
ratified with the European with the UK
government and this political
declaration allows various possible
options but still respecting our
fundamental principles but in any case
whatever happens
ratification of this withdrawal
agreement is necessary it is a
precondition to create a mutual trust
amongst ourselves in the looking forward
to the second round of negotiations
which will start as soon as possible on
our future relationship now with regard
to this future relationship which of
course is the most important thing for
the future for the future of our
continent I would like to remind you
that your Parliament and unanimously the
European Council have always said that
if the United Kingdom chooses to shift
its red lines in the future and if it
makes that choice and it makes a choice
to be more ambitious to go beyond a
simple free-trade agreement which would
be quite something then the European
Union will be immediately ready to go
hand-in-hand with that development and
to give a favourable response so with
regard to the future relationship
president ladies and gentlemen I'm not
only talking about economics and trade
and exchanges that are so important for
growth and jobs I'm talking about
sectoral cooperation and your committees
of course are very very following all
these developments very closely research
for example fisheries very important
sector aviation in transport and many
many other sectors as well I'm talking
about police and judicial cooperation
which will be necessary of course after
brexit and I'm also of course talking
about stability on our continent
security the United Kingdom a large
company a member of the Security Council
of the United Nations a an ally and a
friend will always be a partner in
foreign policy in development and
cooperation and in any matters
pertaining to a defence ladies and
gentlemen we've worked collectively over
the last 18 months and this was
validated at all key moments by the
British government by the European
Council
yourselves here in this European
Parliament now now with this standstill
with the and until we have found a way
forward which will receive a full
majority or a better majority we won't
be able to move forward so this is where
the future steps must be indicated very
clearly as you have said by the British
government president ladies and
gentlemen orderly withdrawal will remain
our absolute priority in the coming
weeks having said that as I speak to you
I mean we cannot exclude any scenario
and this is particularly true of the
scenario we always wanted to avoid and
that was the No Deal scenario it's the
16th of January today we're only 10
weeks away from the end of the month of
March that is to say the moment chosen
by the British government to be for it
to be come a third country and ten weeks
from that date we are fearing more than
ever that there is a risk of a No Deal
and we still are focused on avoiding
that scenario but at the same time we
must remain lucid and clear in our
approach which is why we are stepping up
our efforts to be prepared for that
possibility this work in the services of
the Commission and the Secretariat
general have begun months back with the
Member States and with yourselves in the
Parliament and we will have to speed up
our efforts working together with all
the stakeholders and partners who will
be called on to take contingency
measures to face possible consequences
of that outcome ladies and gentlemen
thank you for your trust in me and us
our conviction I would repeat as Mr
timmermans has reminded us is that the
comp
we reached after 18 months with the
British government remains today the
best possible compromise it is the fruit
of constructive work throughout the
negotiations on both sides it is the
result of an a constructive attitude
which will be ours will be mine to the
very end we must be rain calm we must be
united we must continue dialogue and we
must be transparent it is up to the UK
government now to explain how the UK
will take things forward to organize the
orderly withdrawal that it asked for
itself and beyond that orderly
withdrawal how it will work with us on
building up an ambitious and sustainable
partnership thank you
[Applause]